[Music]
democracy good morning and welcome to
the Vlog it is election week here on
campus so there are a number of um
student positions like student president
VP for activities and post crbs and
stuff and um this is the week where
people campaign to get you to vote for
them which means it's awful I don't like
having people that don't know come up to
me and just start talking to me
[Music]
right so because I've been ill I haven't
really had a chance to do any work but I
did do a bit of coding over the weekend
when I was feeling a bit better and this
morning basically I was going through
what I've written correcting a few
little mistakes and then running
something over lunchtime what I'm doing
is testing all the assumptions in my
thesis and at the
moment I'm not feeling quite so
confident I've yet to run the proper
statistics on it but we we'll see how
good of an assumption it is now normally
election week is my least favorite week
of the year I hate it I absolutely hate
it but this year I have a secret weapon
armed with a campaign t-shirt no one is
going to want to approach me which means
nobody's going to try and give me a
flyer at least that's the
idea this is amazing nobody even wants
to make eye contact with me I should
wear one of these all
[Music]
time I was looking around for you I
didn't see you down here
so this is amazing before it had to be
really worried about the routes I take
through campus to avoid having to talk
to anyone now I'm walking around like a
like a be
knock except no one wants to make eye
contact with me so I just got handed a
free copy of the student newspaper now
normally very cleverly this is called
expose but it's oh oh you see what they
done there exitor is an incredibly pable
name my favorite uh being a football
club uh in one of the leagues that's
called exitor
[Music]
[Applause]
gently so it's half 6 I just finished
work and I am back in the music practice
rooms because there's a lot of music
happening this week Chapel choir is
singing two services this week uh which
isn't that uncommon we are singing an
even song and we're singing a complain
however each of those services are
interesting in their own right this week
because the even song we're singing in
ex to cathedral which is an experience
and secondly the complain is all in
Russian singing in the cathedral is a
lot more difficult than singing in the
chapel because the cathedral has an
acoustic that means you can't really
hear anybody if you're actually sitting
in the choir it's kind of annoying um so
you really need to know the music like
the back of your hand and we are doing
some rather difficult music like the
magnific quinti Tony this stuff however
I'm not overly concerned about it's the
Russian Russian Coral music is
notoriously low now typically as a bass
you expect to sing down to a
g which is kind of the lower limit for a
lot of people's voices sometimes you
cord on to do an
F but that's kind of it in the rat manof
that we're singing on Sunday the N
admitted from his Vespers we're required
to sing A B flat
there's only one person in the choir
that can really do that two kind of and
one of them's me so this week is all
about that bass and all about trying to
extend my lower range so I need to do a
lot of very croaky singing I however
still sound terrible so to save you from
some of my embarrassing singing I'm
going to share this little clip with you
I found uh part of a conchetto for quiet
and baso profundo this gives you some
idea of what Russian cor music sounds
like
[Music]
do you think we maybe had too many
books okay so I just got home and um
Dan's parents are down and they are
helping rebuild our house because
basically we need more storage space so
I just came in and they've completely
rearranged the living room to put more
shelves in now they've offered to take
me out for dinner which is very kind of
them but that leaves me with about an
hour where I can't do anything terribly
productive so I've decided I'm going to
try and go for a slightly longer run
than
normal wish me
luck okay so I'm just walking this off
that's the first I've ever run on my
driver apparently it was only like 6K
but it definitely felt longer than that
I felt like eight oh that might well be
the best or one of the best runs of my
life that felt awesome it also fulfilled
the secondary goal of the run which is
to burn enough calories I can have a
decent meal tonight so we just got back
from a thoroughly Pleasant meal at
Harry's which is probably the nice one
of the nicest restaurants ex to very
least Dan's mom has confirmed herself
has got it going on because our bathroom
is like it it's so clean it's never ever
been this clean she you didn't even ask
her to clean the bathroom she just did
it she just upped and did
it and similarly we just got taken out
for a really nice dinner so thank you
very much for the bathroom and the
dinner danp parents if you're wondering
about this thing you might have seen in
the background I will tell you about
this later in the week now I want to
really quickly just edit together the
days of the Vlog so far and then I'm
going to get some sleep because tomorrow
is a big
day
so today is February 14th which of
course means it's Valentine's Day which
partly explains why I have a little Rose
sticking out my bag like a conning Tower
it's currently about 58 um I am not
actually heading to the office because
Liv said that I'm not allowed to spend
any money on her because screw
traditional gender roles basically I
shouldn't have to spend lots of money so
I didn't spend lots of money I spent a
tiny bit of money sorry and uh I'm
surprising
her
[Music]
look at that desk it's like Lucy Moon
lives
[Music]
[Applause]
here it's going to get
better
I just walked straight past like caers
by four different people nobody paid me
any
attention I feel like Harry Potter in
the invisibility cloak I am a bit
worried though that I might be going a
little bit drunk with power like I
accidentally made ey contact with
someone and they like shied away
oh power the power that we are dealing
with here is immeasurable you just know
that some poor girl had a really really
bad time this morning
ouch so I've come out on the Soggy foggy
balcony of my building to do two things
one I need to reassure you that I'm
smart and I know what I'm doing and then
two I'm going to tell you how I've just
made a massive mistake so firstly I want
to talk about the science that I'm doing
um yesterday I mentioned the fact that I
was testing an assumption we're making
in our Cade now the assumption that I'm
talking about is hydras or that um fluid
we're looking at the atmosphere a b the
hydrostatic equation now this is um a
pretty simple formula it's one of the
most widely used formula in kind of
atmosphere Dynamics and it basically
tells you that the rate of change of
pressure as you go up depends on the
density field and you can actually
derive it very easily if you just
imagine um like two surfaces two
pressure surfaces um that are separated
some distance uh DZ or Delta Zed in part
um and they're labeled you know with
pressure two on the upper surface
pressure one on the lower surface
between them there's a fluid which has
got some density row density is just the
amount of mass per unit volume now let's
say we were interested in trying to
relate those kind of quantities and what
you can say is that the pressure acting
on the bottom surface is going to be the
same as the pressure that's acting on
the top surface whatever that is um plus
the uh product of the
density the distance between the two
surfaces which Delta Z and then G the
acceleration due to gravity because um
you have to remember that uh
Force you get a force by multiplying a
mass by an acceleration if equal if you
do that then you can rearrange it such
that you get finite difference form of
the differential version which is the
one I showed you at the beginning now
this is known to be um a very good
assumption for the whole atmosphere and
I've tested it and shown that to be the
case um you know banging but we don't
know if it applies to our case cuz we're
looking at pressure anomalies not
overall pressure we're looking at um
like differences from the the what you'd
expect in the pressure um over a whole
area so it's not guaranteed that the
assumption would be good uh and I wrote
some code to test that and yesterday I
said that I wasn't too confident um I've
discovered why it wasn't looking so good
because I was using the wrong data
there's loads of different ways that you
can um refer to like surface temperature
and I was using uh sea surface
temperature because I forgot that water
is a different temperature to land well
on Simon so instead of downloading ssts
I now downloaded uh 2 m temperatures
which is like a 2 GB data set it's
currently downloading um and hopefully
fingers crossed that's going to make a
bit more sense when I put it into the
code and this assumption will actually
be just
fine so this year for Valentine's Day Li
and I were thinking of going out for a
meal but everywhere we looked by the
time we actually agreed to do something
for it was uh booked out so we've got
one of these fancy Mark M&S meal deals
um we're going to have a Calon night
I've got a little
surprise and I think we're going to try
and answer some of the questions that
you guys have asked on Twitter about uni
and relationships Mary's Little Worlds
asked how do you deal with the workload
you have whilst maintaining a good
relationship does it ever get in the way
it's all about balance really I mean the
relationship doesn't get in the way as
long as you kind of allocate time just
for that and then you allocate
everything else for doing your work um
keeping relationship to the evenings
generally and then like having lunch
together and stuff I find like keeps
them nice and separate um it is very
possible that one can get in the way of
the other but I I feel like we got we've
kind of managed to get to it's taken a
while to get a pretty good balance
because for one thing we were a
longdistance couple for a year uh before
this year um so it took a bit of an
adjustment but um I feel like you just
establish boundaries really s's asked
what's the most fun vday you've had in
College on like I'm not just saying this
cuz Liv is there it might actually be
today the other ones I just can't
remember that well um last year I sent
you a shoe box full of English things
cuz cuz Liv was in Madrid and it was
like Marite cab bre um there was wine it
was it that was it was like a
Valentine's kit for you could have a
date by yourself there was like a little
wine bottle and stuff like that and like
a lush there was like a lush thing it
was awesome Penny's asked have you got a
favorite romcom does Mean Girls count as
a romcom yeah mean girls but what like I
mean like say star that's definitely
that's not
wrong sick boys ask what is love uh baby
don't hurt me don't hurt me no
more happy little birthday why if you
got a book on reading the hieroglyphics
I wanted to learn hieroglyphics uh Keith
asked why is it so difficult to ask
someone out I am the worst person to ask
for this because I have I've only asked
one person out and we were basically in
a relationship with that Point anyway I
still have yet to properly ask you out
yeah you're not actually my boyfriend
sorry we Facebook official I think it's
difficult to ask somebody out to
seriously answer the question because
you're afraid of you know like so you're
put putting yourself out there and
afraid of being rejected um it's a lot
like a lot of other anxieties I think
and uh similar to advice I gave I think
in the last Vlog I think you just got to
say balls to it and just just try
because if you know you miss 100% of the
shots you don't take uh Charlie's asked
any ideas for celebrating Valentine's
Day in a long-distance relationship so
we did the the whole I sent you a date
care package Marmite is the key Marmite
is key I mean what we kind of did was
what we did later in the year was We did
an Airbnb we like we met in N um which
was I thought half over between Spain
and ex U we got an Airbnb and we just we
hung out in the city for like a couple
of days and it was just really chill it
was really really nice and I feel like
that would have been the perfect thing
to do for Valentine's if we if it had
worked out that way Caitlyn's asked me
and my boyfriend are going to different
unions will it change our Outlook on
each other too much um this is a really
prickly subject because there are no
hard and fast rules that apply to
everybody my personal opinion is that if
you're in a relationship in school and
you're going to different universities
It generally doesn't work out um just
just sort of from experience uh and from
seeing other friends doing it um I
personally wish that I hadn't carried my
relationship from school on University
um which is something that my ex
actually agrees with interestingly I'm
not just being horrible I was going to
say you can't say that
but that's only my personal experience
um it's just happened to be that for my
friendship group and for me it didn't
work out um I think the important thing
to do is to give each other enough space
when you are at different universities
stay in contact like obviously and you
know maybe not talk every day but
certainly talk several times a week see
each other as frequently as you can but
like allow each other to develop
friendship groups because I feel like
one of the problems I had at Oxford was
um it was almost like uh holding to the
rigging really really fast in a storm
and I didn't like let go when the storm
was passed and I was just like clinging
onto the relationship when actually I
was missing out on making friendships
and and having my own social group um
which was damaging so I feel like you've
kind of you've kind of got to like not
let go but you've got to give each other
enough space Darius has asked what's the
best SL worst love story you've
heard our
worst
I am on with the force and the Force is
with me I am on with the force and the
Force is with me I to are close cool I
didn't even have my t-shirt on somehow
made it out
[Music]
alive
so today I've accomplished almost
impressively little between having a
line after Valentine's Day and having to
go to the cathedral early for even song
um just haven't been able to do very
much really continue to test this
approximation there's one it's looking a
lot better now but there's one data
point there the surface which is still
doesn't really make a lot of sense so
fixing that and then tomorrow I'll be
moving on to the next stage of kind of
like proving what we're doing makes
sense now though is time for me to head
to the cathedral to sing even song there
with the University of chapelo
[Music]
me not
all
[Music]
so the service went fine
um right so this actually HS back to
what I said before um I me mentioned on
Monday I think that it's much more
difficult to sing in the cathedral um
because you can't hear other people you
can't hear what other parts are doing
it's it's we a weird effect where if
you're actually sat in the congregation
or in the audience you can hear
everything fine but in the choir and
that's Qi like actually sat where the
choir sits um it's very difficult to
hear anything other than your part so
the Bas ones thought well service went
pretty great and apparently a few of the
parts messed up um all I can say is that
for us it sounded fine the cathedral is
a really interesting building um I'd
love to do a video about its history um
it was founded
in 1400 ad uh which means it's not the
oldest or the biggest cathedral in the
country by a long way but it is a world
record holder in that it is the longest
continuous Nave like the middle bit
because it doesn't have a tower in the
middle it has a tower on either side so
that Nave goes right the way down for 96
M but like I said last Vlog I love this
quite a bit and and when I graduate I am
really really going to miss
[Applause]
it okay I might have made a mistake so
last night I uh got back I did some talk
to you about the even song and uh eight
and then I was like I'll just do a bit
of editing just you
know I'm working on the brain chemistry
video it's nearly finished um I emailed
some questions to the scientist who I
interviewed and I was doing some
animating and I thought let's just sort
of grind it out unfortunately I then
stopped at like 3:00 a.m. this is where
things come back to the work life
balance um and also the work work
balance cuz it's like I'm doing two jobs
so you up
yeah oh
sake thanks
mate oh my God what's my
head D has conf vinced the people on our
group chat that I drank an entire Bott
of whiskey last night which is so much
less embarrassing than the actual truth
I was editing atoms until 3:00 a.m. if
I'm being honest I don't often let the
YouTube get in the way genuinely I think
I'm pretty good
um but last night yeah that was
definitely the needle suway too far one
way
[Music]
well I was just caught singing just sort
of walking through a corridor turn
around the corner and there was a guy I
mean he said it sounded nice so so this
afternoon um like I said yesterday I was
kind of clearing up what I've been doing
for the past couple of days but um
one of the reasons I've been doing this
is because I've been skirting around one
of the big issues which is the assumed
equivalence of two techniques uh
basically looking when I talk about Mass
fluxes I'm talking about the actual
weight the mass of air that is moving um
from out of the polar regions into the
polar regions and our way of calculating
that is definitely wrong oh
hello hi hello hi Simon's
followers now that method being wrong
isn't actually that big of a problem f
enough being wrong is something of a
specialty of mine it's the fact that I
don't actually know how to even approach
trying to fix
[Music]
[Applause]
it so two other bits of news one my man
is comeback so I feel terrible um but
two I just made the terrible mistake of
voicing my true opinions about something
on Twitter which is that tea is weird
and disgusting I don't do hot drinks I
don't drink tea or coffee or hot
chocolate and to me people that drink
tea are really weird because it's I it's
a foul substance right and this is going
to cause a real storm in the comments I
know I don't care cuz I know I'm right
te's really weird all right yeah okay so
Liv and I are just on the way to Chapel
choir and there's this mural up which is
the hash never Campaign which is all
about ending like sexual abuse on campus
and how it's never okay to do it however
so you know that there are lots of
signatures right there are lots and lots
of people uh and clubs uh for example
like X University women's rugby football
club however I've only just
noticed apparently Jimmy savle is at
this University and thinks it's it's
never okay it's a bit late I think I did
not see that apparently the guil didn't
either for some reason I wasn't even was
angry
that's going in I hope you
realize the f I think it goes um the
evening hangs beneath the
moon something it's I mean you're a
tener bless you oh sorry there's three
Flats so we're about to record Another
Piece we're stared doing this every week
where we just record one of the things
that we've learned uh and this time
around is some stuff by Eric
wit
[Music]
okay so I think I'm being very stupid
but I kind of as a rule never let that
stop me from doing stuff I need to do so
last night I came down Sick in a big way
um I was like physically shaking um I
was freezing even though the house
wasn't cold I had headache earache um
just you know that early onset of oh
hello that early onset stage of being
ill having a flu um I haven't had it
that bad in
years so I woke up at
5:30 um determined not to miss this
meeting I have tomorrow have this today
I'm a little bit Delirious I was
determined not to miss the supervision I
have with both supervisors today because
cuz it's a very important one this
assumption about the mass fluxes that
I've been testing this week it's a
really really huge part of my thesis
it's very important
pillar and if we don't get that working
there's no
PhD so I need to print out some graphs
that I've been working on um because
there are there's lots of stuff to
report in terms of progress um because I
haven't se many supervisors for a couple
of weeks there's lots of stuff to talk
about I just need to print it out and uh
talk about it then draw up a plan of
action what I want to talk about in the
meeting which I do know everything's up
here I just need to formalize it then
after the 10:00
meeting I don't know maybe we'll go back
to bed who knows at least I don't have
to worry about election week campaigners
at this
[Music]
time
there are definite perks to be on campus
this
early so physically what do you
conclude well phys physically the
density anomalies are Mo are
hydrostatically distributed in the lower
atmosphere but not quite hydrostatically
distributed above 20 km look at this
carbon fiber desk how
professional supervision done that
actually went fine Tom and I both
talking about our Theses which are kind
of coming along vaguely nicely yeah not
too bad also getting here getting out of
the uh the building uh from our
supervisor's office involves us going
through an inordinate number of
doors one two three 4 5
five six seven seven thank
you
eight
nine
and your soul is my heart R out so I've
come home because I cannot concentrate
like every time I move I can feel my
brain like slushing around in my skull
um which is really really painful when I
cough or sneeze which I'm doing a lot of
hang on there's actually a story about
how I acquired that lamp uh which is
going to come out in a vlog about what I
was doing in Belfast in a couple of
weeks it's not actually long now so
basically this afternoon I am forcing
myself to take a break because as
everybody's been telling me um if I rest
now I'm going to get better faster and I
will be able to be productive in the
future cuz I I I just can't stand being
ill I can't I I judge how good a day was
by how productive I was how many tasks I
accomplished when I me I can't I can't
do anything I can't even edit um I'm
reduced to watching yast streams and
feeling sorry for myself now the form of
those is great and I love it but I I do
just struggle giving myself recovery
time um my welfare is very low on my uh
priority list
basically so no singing practice no more
coding um although the supervision did
go okay there's a lot to talk about next
week with my second supervisor talking
about the damx because my statistical
analysis of the data sets has thrown up
something which we weren't expecting at
all um it's good that we call it now
rather than you know a month before I
submit but
um yeah a lot of work needs to be
done but not
[Music]
today so this morning I've been working
on editing um I've been trying to put
the finishing touches to this brain
chemistry video which I realized in the
last Vlog I said might be out and I'm
still working on it um it's because the
animation in this is actually quite by
my standards uh in detailed in detailed
detailed I'm also still ill like I've
moved on to the coughing stage but I'm a
bit Delirious still it also allows me to
mention this again so this thing is a
road nt1a condenser mic microphone and
it is a vocal microphone specifically so
when I've done stuff in the past I've
been using a shotgun microphone like an
ntg2 um or I've been using a lavalier
sometimes um me buying this represents
me actually specializing audio equipment
and it's one of the last um bits in my
Armory um basically as I've um been
moving towards finishing the PHD and
moving towards going into video
production as like a full-time thing um
I've been sort of gradually hoarding kit
and hoarding software and um learning
how to do things um and this is one of
the last pieces in the puzzle um because
doing voice overs is you know quite an
important part if you're going to do
videos for other people um and also if I
want to do inform informational videos
like the brain chemistry video I needed
to have like an actually good uh a good
good sounding voice over so I've had my
own one for quite some time and um I
finally just went balls to it I I I I
spent Again YouTube money money as I
famously defined it last time that comes
from YouTube
on actually upgrading and I'm really
glad I did because the difference is
unbelievable this thing sounds so good
if you're wondering by the way this is
the microphone itself um this is a shock
mount that stops vibrations from
affecting it and this thing is what's
called a pop Shield or a pop filter um
so it stops what uh what are called
plosives so if I say like P or t you
probably I've got a muffler on the
camera um so you won't be able to tell
uh but but normally on a microphone that
you hear it as like a a wall of of sound
it's like a W uh because um it's like a
shock wave that hits the microphone what
the pop filter does is it removes that
shock wave so the sound still goes
through but um the shock wave in the air
is stopped um so it's absolutely
essential because when you actually do
like vocal stuff you're like here which
is what I'm going to do now because I
need to re-record a voice over for the
brain chemistry video don't think that I
haven't in the comments I apparently
have been missing out my entire life as
an adult on this technique that you just
turn the duo cover inside out I'm just
going to say this guys this seems much
more confusing than my
method all right I can see why people do
it this
way but it's I'm not convinced it's
better I mean it's possible that this
has giv it a better distribution within
the DU but I'm not
I'm not a convert guys and here we the
deliver the breeding season for delivery
drivers are started early this
year so you join me several hours later
um earlier in the evening we have been
to Bo to play games fictitious children
looking after a
personin you're on the right track Nanny
MC lost in the sea y basically a friend
of mine is visiting from back home who
was chosen to remain nameless um for
very good reasons but we are now in
Firehouse this is somewhere I've
actually mentioned before but never
probably shown this is my by far my
favorite Pub in the world uh as you can
see behind me it's just really cool
really so this has actually got some
literary history to it this was meant to
be the Pu that inspired the NY cauldron
in Harry Potter personally this always
felt like more of a um free broomstick
kind of vibe but I'm not JK ring so
whatever the reason we're here is
because obviously it's very cool pum but
also it has really good pizzas like this
is some of the best pizza I've ever had
in my life so we are going to stay here
get Bev and get really fat I'll see you
tomorrow why is this not called
criminali So today we're going to go um
and take a walk with my friends from
home uh to a pub but um we just
discovered that last night Liv tried to
fix my my gorilla pod these legs are
meant to be
equal you just you just ran them in
there so I also wanted to talk this
morning about a little bit of science
because as um I mentioned at the start
of the Vlog this week today uh we're
doing a service where we I have to sing
very very low now there are various ways
you can train your voice to sing low um
there is also a dirty rotten trick which
is to use a drug the way that this drug
works is that basically it artificially
loosens your vocal cords because the
note that you produce basically is a
combination of the air that you push
over your vocal cords and the tension of
those vocal cords in simple terms um and
so what P does is it loosens them and um
causes your entire like voice to drop
down so this morning I sound a bit lower
and I'm very capable of hitting notes as
live will a test because last night we
all took in a fair bit of this drug
which is alcohol basically if you're
hung over you can sing low and it is a
legitimate strategy if you're a base in
some choirs to just get smashed the day
before oh really so we're at the pub and
these two guys are fishing and they've
caught what looks to be the biggest fish
in the entire
River look at
that that's like 3 foot long at
least oh no
God you filming what you just done so
hang on this is the worst lighting up
what have you two just done so we
brought the Drone with us to this Pub
which is double locks and which is a
lovely Pub just outside ex to we brought
the Drone because we want to get some
aerial shots except I forgot to pack the
memory card for the Drone so we just had
a we had a really fun time just showing
off the Drone and my friend uh from home
was just flying it so not a total
failure but no footage to show frze cuz
I'm an idiot apart from this lovely Pub
honestly if you're next to come here is
so nice double looks #
notp I let you into my house mate you
know who you are I said I'm not going to
name you but you know who you are I let
you stay in my room and what do you
repay me with you come to my house okay
so we're about to leave compin and um an
interesting thing transpired which is
that two of our second bases are now not
available one stuck on a train and the
other is ill so me and Peter are being
moved normally I'm over there today I am
here because I'm a low
[Music]
base
nice job
[Music]
Sarah now it all right so we just stand
compling actually feel a bit of
configurated because we made it we
actually hit the V flat in the the N
which I wasn't entirely sure we were
going to do now I tried to record it I
don't know how it's going to come out
but apparently it sounded good in
context
so
[Music]
yes
other vits this week might not g so well
the work might not have gone so great I
might be feeling ill but
ah Managed IT that's a
[Music]
victory
CL
[Music]
my
see my
[Music]
might
right
shine
[Music]
to
heart
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
the
[Music]
s
SLE